Now you're from Boston.
So you from the safe suburbs ever since Goodwill hunting came out,
everybody thinks everyone from the Boston area lived in Southie and got into
fights and smashed bottles over people's heads because you play a tough guy
doesn't mean lace curtain, Irish
[inaudible]
[inaudible].
When you think of Boston, what comes to mind? World-class universities,
the Irish Marky, Mark, whatever you think of,
it's likely influenced by the many iconic films set there,
but movies like Goodwill hunting and the department didn't come up with the
Boston identity out of nowhere,
it comes in part from the history of the city itself.
A history largely defined by the conflict between working class Catholics and
the wealthier Protestant elite in the 18th and 19th century.
The Boston ruling class consisted exclusively of British Protestants associated
with elite Cambridge universities, but in the 18 hundreds,
thousands of Irish immigrated to Boston and threatened the Protestant control.
The Boston community responded with systemic discrimination,
early loss in Boston,
outright banned Catholicism and Irish people couldn't attend.
Ivy league schools.
Poor Irish communities were relegated to South Boston below the Charles river.
But as their numbers grew, Irish people gained political control of the city.
After an Irishman, couldn't get a job. We had the president.
The Boston Irish history created a cultural identity around being the underdog,
even though they became the ones in power.
And it's from the old conflict between Protestant and Catholic,
British and Irish and Cambridge and South Boston that we see where Boston
stereotypes come from. So let's get into it.
Well, because you have the same kind of background. My background, Oh,
you're from the same neighborhood he's from Southie.
The subtext of Goodwill hunting is the conflict between the Cambridge elite and
poor Irish Catholics.
The film regularly establishes Southie as Irish through color scheme,
the opening shot shows an Irish flag over Will's fireplace.
The next several shots all have some form of that green, white,
and orange color scheme associated with the Irish flag.
The most compelling example in the beginning is the green, white,
and orange buildings they drive past.
But the color scheme is also in the shot of the old woman on her porch.
The characters even wear them Chucky with his white and green jacket and will
with his orange and maroon one,
all these shots established Southie and to the people in it.
As Irish as throughout the rest of the movie,
they constantly surround themselves with green Irish imagery in gritty
neighborhood bars.
The neon sign next to Chuckie is a Shamrock with Southie written inside it.
And all these Irish blue collar areas are the exact opposite of this.
[Inaudible].
It's polished, perfectly matching and elitist.
Instead of the Irish flag shots of the Cambridge elite have American flags in
the background.
We see this imagery most prominently in the Harvard bar behind the pretentious
Harvard students. And of course,
as Chuckie tries to impress the girls with his knowledge,
he has a Guinness sign him in the movie.
The American flag is always associated with the people at odds with the poor
Irish from Southie. There are American flags behind the intellectual elite,
the justice system and big government,
and the film regularly places will within that conflict,
fighting the pressures to become a certain type of American ideal Sean's office
is the room where will comes to terms with his past and figures out what to do
with his life.
It's no coincidence that this room has both an American flag and Irish
paraphernalia.
The film establishes the specific Cambridge Southie conflict in Boston,
but it doesn't really give a solution for it.
Instead of deciding either to remain in Southie or get a white collar job,
we'll abandon the conflict altogether and goes out West by making this maneuver.
It carefully sidesteps the conflict between the elites and the Irish.
He doesn't have to pick a side,
but not every Irish movie has clear Irish and American imagery like in Goodwill
hunting. Some movies show the conflict in different ways.
Manchester by the sea shows the class divide in Boston.
Although it does only take place in the greater Boston area.
In the opening montage,
Lee works as a handyman and a Southern Boston suburb that night.
He goes to a bar and has a stare down with what the script describes as two
businessmen. He then starts a fistfight with them.
It's no coincidence that the movie establishes Lee as blue collar.
And then right after that, he picks a fight with two white collar men,
but a more unexpected conflict happens later when Patrick visits his born again,
a mom and her new fiance, Jeffrey,
the scene shows how the Irish in Boston also stand out by being Catholic instead
of Protestant.
So you can say, amen, Patrick, nobody's trying to recruit you.
In the 18 hundreds laws in Boston discriminated against Catholics.
While the legal distinction is long gone.
The cultural differences between Catholics and Protestants have stayed
Manchester by the sea.
It uses this religious conflict to reinforce the emotional distance between
Patrick and his mother. It's a subtle distinction, rarely seen in Boston movies,
but it's still an underlying component of what makes Protestant America feel
different from Irish Catholic.
It was very Christian, you know, work Christian too, right? Yes.
I know that you are aware of the Catholics are Christians.
It's worth noting that before the mother gets her life together.
She's a drug addict who abandoned her family.
It's a pretty common trope in Boston movies to have a blue collar identity in
women come off as unseemly while in men it's charming in gone, baby gone,
Helene McCready's character is a junkie and an irresponsible mother.
So the characters in power decide what's best for her and her daughter,
whether it's the detectives or her working class,
brother-in-law everyone seems to want to take away Helene's agency compare
Helene to Madeline in the department.
Madeline is educated and wears a Harvard t-shirt indicating that she's
upper-class superior. Cause she went to college for Colin Sullivan.
She's his trophy for breaking free from his Southy background.
Women in Boston movies are commonly either deserving of pity or a status symbol.
There are another way for Boston movies to create distinct differences between
groups I'd argue that you can even see a subtle difference between the two
groups in something as simple as coffee.
Fancy coffee is for snobs into outsiders, right?
Might get me a cup of coffee for the hell. Is it a cafe.
Dilemma? And Dunkin donuts is for the average American, like.
The mayor of Dunkin is the face and Dunkin donuts, right? I like Dunkin donuts,
but have you been to a Dunkin donuts that doesn't have a homeless guy standing
in front? Is that part of the design plans?
Even though Dunkin donuts is actually a popular nationwide chain,
it's become a signal of blue collar people in film and TV.
So in the case of a Boston movie,
people who drink Duncan must also be from Southie man. It's the same.
As Dunkin donuts costs just in terms of price.
But Irish imagery,
religious differences and taste and coffee only show up in some of the Boston
movies.
There is one symbol of the Southeast Cambridge conflict that almost every Boston
movie has the Charles river neighborhood.
Every Boston movie understands that the Charles river separates the elites from
the poor.
When the poor Irish people want to do a hit or a robbery or go to their day job,
there is always a shot from South looking North towards the Charles river at
Cambridge or downtown Boston as expected in the town.
The camera's starts South of Boston. And the first robbery is in Cambridge,
right outside the Harvard subway station.
And this geographic distinction is historically accurate.
Irish immigrants often crossed the Fort point channel and Charles river to work
in blue collar jobs for academic and to upper-class institutions.
Boston movies have always established this division,
but they challenge it differently depending on the movie and movies like the
boondock saints, the town and domestic river,
the Irish decide to operate outside of the system that oppresses them and take
the law into their own hands.
They fulfill the fantasy that a person doesn't have to subject themselves to the
unfairness of the current legal system. Instead they criminally work around it,
forming their own gangs, who exploit or take down the system,
a system represented by cops,
the government or the upper-class in these Boston movies.
It's always us versus them,
but all the stereotyping and generalizing begs the question are the lines that
clearly drawn according to the department. They're not.
When I was your age,
they would say we could become cops or criminals today.
What I'm saying is this. When you're facing a loaded gun,
what's the difference.
Instead of fighting the system,
the department tries to infiltrate it from within the film quickly establishes
the two groups early on,
instead of Cambridge elite society is represented by the Boston state house.
I mean, you move in your upper class by about Tuesday. Unlike will hunting.
Common wants to rise into upper society. What are you looking at?
And because he's not a super genius,
he's held back by his background on his way up.
Got it. Your father was a janitor. The son's only a cop.
So you're a cop as state police, detective I'm one more up. Oh,
fancy policeman. Yeah, that's right. Yeah.
Collin's a criminal. Just like the characters in other Boston movies.
But with one big difference, he's trying to go legit.
Despite the blurring of groups and the characters attempt to rise above his
origins in Southie the movie has a depressing message,
but if you're a rat and you're from Southeast,
no matter how much you try to rise up, you'll pay the price.
Are always rising, a fallen in America. My right.
We said that Hawthorne.
And for Billy cost again, it's all the same.
Even though he tries to do the right thing.
How can families dive into this healthy projects like ticks.
Three deck amend at best? I know your father was a man.
Could have been anything.
Are you trying to say that he was nothing saying he worked at the airport?
I know what you are. Okay. I know what you are. And I know what you're not.
I'm the best friend you have on the face of this earth.
And I'm gonna help you understand something you punk, you know, cough.
The tragedy of the department is that despite how hard the characters try to
escape the circumstances of their birth,
they still suffer the fate of a common criminal.
When they were born into a lower class Irish family in the South of Boston,
their future was sealed,
But the departed aunts, all other Boston movies,
miss the true reality of the Boston Irish, they did escape their roots in South.
The end did make their way to the state house. After the Irish gained control,
the wealth discrimination,
the religious conflict and the geographic separation of the rich and the poor
still existed. But the Irish became the leaders of Boston and in doing so,
they gradually turned what was once a marginalized identity into an identity
that the whole city embraced.
So movies about Boston focus on the memory of Irish people as the underdogs who
struggled to overcome their repression by the Cambridge elite,
Goodwill hunting and other Boston movies become so iconic because they
understand this Irish underdog story.
And to the success of Goodwill hunting made this Irish identity understood
outside of Boston. Now Boston Southie and the Irish are inseparable.
[Inaudible].
Matt Damon and Ben Aflac made such a groundbreaking movie by placing their own
fictional story within the actual Boston environment of the 1990s,
they achieved the perfect balance of truth and style that many Boston movies
have since tried to emulate this balance is something I think about when I write
these videos, make it flashy, but keep it true. Author Susan,
or lean talks about the importance of finding your style when writing nonfiction
as the writer of the book that inspired the film adaptation,
she clearly understands how a great story uses elements of truth to deliver its
message.
She speaks at length about creative non-fiction storytelling and an amazing
original series on Skillshare.
Skillshare is an online learning platform with thousands of classes in creative
writing, video editing and more premium membership,
lets you use classes that fit your interests and you have the option to get the
annual subscription and awesome deal that comes out to less than $10 a month.
But if you're not ready to commit yet,
just click on the link in the description and get two months of free access.
You can see Susan Orleans class and thousands of others across tons of topics,
a big thank you to Skillshare and to my Patrion supporters who make this channel
possible.